um let's do the
the one drill where you're trying to hit
the chest okay okay
and uh i'm doing my stuff
okay so uh let's look at this
uh why is your arm
uh stuck on stuff there
let's go back rewind the film what do
so what what do you feel what how
describe it to me so what do you feel
now
nothing can you move your arm yes yes
okay
go go back we're gonna show you
something come on so
i'm gonna uh do it as she's rewinding do
you feel it
i'm gonna lower her
do you see how it turned her okay so
uh i'll do the other one you see it
comes off
you see that okay so i i want you
to uh feel
why or what is what are you feeling why
is your arm
extended and still touching mine what do
you feel
pressure at all speak up there's like a
pressure on it at all
a pressure so like a squeezy no like a
like a touch of pressure but not a
squeeze like a touch pressure
okay so it doesn't allow me to
really really okay let's try it again so
uh so i i think i'm pressure like this
okay so if i go like this did it feel
like that
okay let's do it again and let's see if
you can get out of that pressure
yes you see okay so what
do you describe it better then almost
like you have a connection
a point of connection on my body you
have a point of connection on my body
that
has control in that point okay
all right and then you can't pull your
arm off right here
and and you can see that uh i
i can uh pull you you see
which is why if you if you try to if you
try to pull your arm
it just makes it more of a turn you see
that did you feel that
okay uh
now i want you to feel this let's say
you you
move your arm off of my hand do you see
okay and you go did you move it off no
okay why you kind of want me i went with
you right
so if you moved your arm off and i
stayed here it would work
but if you go off and i stay with you
it's not disconnected okay
now i'll show you uh i'm gonna be
okay okay and i want you to feel
this okay so you're i'm gonna try to hit
you
good what happened there
you did not follow okay so you
yes there you go okay good
and what happened here um
okay he didn't follow again okay
good good good
so you you're just following right don't
follow anymore
then you see my arms come on okay so you
follow and our arms don't uh
disconnect but what are you not doing
the body no of these two
forces so i had one where i'm pulling
you see i create
that adhesion and then the other one
where you brought your arm off
right and i followed there's two
different ways that our hands stay
connected
you don't have the adhesion one okay do
you guys see that
okay which is why i'm able to stay
perfectly upright so i try to touch you
and you can maybe stick to me but
you don't affect my balance do you get
it okay
so as you're going to do the drill
and i want you to feel the different
ways that i'm staying stuck to you
see if you can verbalize when when it's
a following
and when it's at adhering i'm hearing
okay
good following good and something else
is happening
if you pay attention uh let's say for
example
you disconnect right now disconnect
did you still fall yeah okay yes
just connect do you see
disconnect do you see do you see that
okay so that felt very weird to you
right to disconnect because you knew you
were gonna fall
right um so let's look at
let's let's slow down that motion where
you're teetering do you see
uh did you feel your pressure increase
here okay
uh decrease that pressure
do you see what's happening to you
what's happening to you
what's happening to your balance you're
falling okay
so why did you increase pressure on the
arm
to keep your balance do you see that so
as i go i there's an adhesion right here
okay just stay there i'll show you
but you press into the adhesion
to keep your balance right if you take
off that
so you can watch if you push really hard
into the adhesion
you can balance there you see that okay
and now as you start taking away really
you can take more into the tilt just
push into the extrusion
and you're using my face as your balance
do you see
you you're very precarious right now
right now if you take away that pressure
look what's going to happen take it away
she'll go into the following okay so
there's
three things to realize one is the
adhesion skill
which is an internal skill two is the
following skill
where i keep connected to her and three
is a psychological effect of the
adhesion
being used to take kazushi the person
will feed the adhesion
to maintain their balance longer you see
it
that's why she doesn't pull the arm in
at that point
if she did pull the arm in and i wanted
to keep connection what would i do just
follow it in
you see you followed it in the arm and
still be stuck on mine
what is different from those three
things
that is uh me as ukip
staying connected to you do you see that
so this is what that looks like i'll do
you go around
you can't tell who's nagged do you see
that
do you get that so in the other one
you're trying to
hit that but somehow our hands stay
connected all through those three ways
okay let's try okay uh when i
what i want let me have it on what i
want you to do is
do it like that got it
as fast as you can not on me just out of
space
go good do it again
okay and again as fast as you can
go good okay now
what i want you to do is do that as fast
as you can
and then pull out and come back in
okay when did you notice about her
second thrust
let's do it again fast you can begin
fast you can't out
what do you think
watch how long it takes her to go slow
in
go slow in and then out and then slow in
out fast
now go faster fast out fasted
that's hard what do you think
what do you notice
there's a lot more time why is there
more time
go dude do it
why is there more time going in and out
because i have to
try to make that distance again nope
i'll show you
i'll do it on you okay so i'm gonna go
one two five
why is that so much faster than yours
let's amplify your energy you're going
to go in go
[Music]
okay so what are you fighting to come
back
out what are you fighting
her forward momentum do you see that
let's do it again
yo you see
can't come can't pull up okay
um let's look at the next thing
um where are you picturing me
in the attack do it again
right here okay
so you're gonna go
what are you gonna do
okay let's do it again there we go
oh okay so if i stay here
[Music]
right now do you see it do it again
okay now let's do it again okay
sorry here grab my heat and go
good and again good
now do it come on oh
it looks different doesn't it
i gotta go like this right i gotta do
something like this
oh you had to change it didn't you
okay so what is this showing
this looks pretty good but because i
stayed here
when i don't stay here
that looks stupid do you see
so it's what i did that made that look
practical
and like i had to do
but if i just go she has to do something
all of a sudden she's lunging
do you see all of a sudden you're
lunging
right okay third thing
let's go back to this
so she goes
good come again go
i'm gonna add inertia to it
go okay
now tell me if the knife comes all the
way back
no it doesn't okay
because it's hard to bring it all the
way back because your momentum is going
this way
do you see it's hard to go reverse
motion
so now face me
and she comes in with the knife here
i'm moving but if i move over here
it's the same thing as i'm not where
that range is
do you see that so we'll do it again
and let's pull the knife
in
what are you here to see
okay let's slow it down so you see
so the first one is i'm not there
so she has to latch in
then there's this stay still
i'm gonna have her not come forward
there's this
[Music]
do you see there's that adhesion
so her arm is is committed to the thrust
that's why it extends it's hard to pull
back
because she's being thrown forward but
there's an adhesion
that keeps it long you see that
where's the momentum come from
on the backhand so
violence goes do you feel what you did
when balance goes
what did you do i tried to put pressure
she's putting pressure on me
because her balance is going right
so feel that indeed
not so great enough to make you take a
step
but when we ask them they can get
tighter
because you don't want to fall okay
so it's not that she's keeping it out
there and stuck to me and so i moved
kept an adhesion took her balance
she braces on me the knife is stuck
on me okay let's try okay so
uh the first is coming in but she's not
there
you're gonna come in the knife this way
this way
do that same get us to the tip there you
go don't go backwards
come forward forward yes there it is
right there
okay so rodent resisted
the throat he resisted but he got some
bottles taken off
you see
so
[Music]
so my attack is
coming
what happened to your arm
so let's go back i go one
balance this makes no sense
this makes sense
i go underneath your energy
[Music]
what does this resemble what am i doing
what am i doing anyway
i'm trying to go around your check why
did i go around your check
anyone louder
no adhesion because you left it there
you see
follow it follow it
here oh you go one
there's that balance you see did you
come underneath
underneath boom that's it
underneath yes
so what's causing the delay between the
two
um regain your balance right
so boom there is you got it
okay now do you you tell me why
go what happened
left touching okay so
whoa doesn't leave touching you go
up up
yes
it's not that you're leaving your arm
out what is it
i followed it you see to the next
adhesion
[Music]
to stay with it
okay try it so let's say i i'm
coming in you do the balance right and i
go like this and i pull the knife back
would be a disengagement
you see we would start all over again so
you could do that entry or you could
just back up again and get this
do you understand so the other the other
one
is the actual continuation of the attack
once you enter into this spot here
we'll get my balance to pull the knife
which could happen right so now you come
here
it pulls the knife back you see that's
your time to move
draw your own knife what have you
but you could also follow it in right so
a long balance and you follow it in you
see
you just follow it in you would just do
the same following
okay trying to get around
it is much smarter so
we'll come back to seated
you're naked and i want to get
off of this block you see well if i go
back
it's easier for you to follow it easier
for you to follow it right but if i go
around it
it's much harder around it
going back and forth easy easy for her
to follow
okay you see let's start going around it
way okay
hey does that answer
it that's why ronan did it he's trying
to get me
he's not trying not to get me the other
one would not get me at all
okay